elon musk was asked by a donor what the
republican party needs to do better
and elon musk said that the gop needs to
be more compassionate on immigration
he says that the gop needs to be more
compassionate to potential newcomers and
he noted that
this is
he believes this in part because he
chose america for its opportunities he
says immigrants are vital to maintaining
a dynamic economy
how much more welcoming to newcomers can
we be
we let in millions of people every year
we allow one million people to come into
this country every year legally and
almost no one is even challenging that
even though the vast majority of the
american people on poll after poll
reflect and express that they want to
drastically reduce the number of legal
immigrants who are brought into this
country by about 60 percent
still no one in either of the major
parties really talks about that
very few people
then on top of the million legal
immigrants we allow in every year we
allow 2 million illegal immigrants it's
probably going to be more than that this
year under biden and we've done this for
decades now the numbers have increased
pretty dramatically recently but we've
allowed
untold
masses of foreign nationals to pour into
our country and then we give them all
kinds of goodies and we give them all
kinds of resources and we allow them to
participate in our government we give
them the rights of citizens in many
cases
how much more compassionate can we be
i think
i think we've been a little maybe a
little overly compassionate not
compassionate enough to our own citizens
i think we've been a little reckless
actually and imprudent
how much more compassionate can you
possibly
be this is an issue of meta-politics
this is not just an issue of the
immigrants it's an issue of
meta-politics
the movement of immigrants into america
over the past
uh 60 years or so is the largest
migration of people ever in recorded
history
how much more compassionate can we be
what that does is it changes our
political landscape the reason the
democrats encourage this the reason the
democrats changed all our immigration
laws
is because they feel
that by changing the makeup of the
country the actual people in the country
they will get an electoral advantage
and the data bear that out maybe not as
much of an advantage as they think that
they're getting
but it will give them an advantage a
generational advantage as well and they
know it and they brag about it and
they've been bragging about this in
academic papers and in the mainstream
media for 20 years now
and the republicans are supposed to
what go even more in that direction i
don't think so that's called not only is
that reckless not only is that wrong
politically it's also suicidal right now
go to goodranchers.com
knowles
regardless of what the biden
administration defines as a recession
americans are worried they're feeling it
food and gas prices are higher than i've
ever seen in my lifetime that is why i
am so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers good ranchers offers an
inflation-proof subscription model that
lets you lock in your price the day you
subscribe i don't know how this works i
hope good ranchers can stay in business
this is such a good deal
you you subscribe right now you can
either buy a box of meat
absolutely top quality meat you just buy
a one-off box and you enjoy it or you
can subscribe and for the whole life of
your subscription it will never go up
do it right now this is the most insane
deal i've ever seen goodranchews.com
knowles use code nols at checkout you
get 30 bucks off plus free shipping lock
in that price recession proof your meals
for life inflation proof your meals for
life you'll be automatically entered to
win 30 minutes by the way of all access
with me on september 30th if you do that
this offer ends august 31st we're
calling it a meet and greet go to
goodranchers.com
use code knowles at checkout
hey michael my name is brayden i just
listened to your episode where you
talked about essentially the immorality
of a homosexual couple
adopting
a child just the concept in general my
question is what about those children
that
need a home absolutely need a home need
to be adopted what have you
and a broken home is better than no home
at all and you have a loving homosexual
couple willing to take them in
and be a caretaker
and a guardian for that child i'm just
curious your response to that thank you
well we've gotta distinguish between two
radically different forms of adoption
one is the adoption of newborn babies
and the other is the fostering of
children who are in orphanages usually
run by the state
those are very very different types of
abortion
and the libs and the radicals who want
to
redefine the family and who want to
mainstream things like single parent
adoption or homosexual adoption
they they try to conflate the two
because it's helpful for their argument
but we i think we would all grant those
are very different types of adoption
and
in the case of the adoption of newborns
the premise of your question ceases to
make sense because what you will hear is
as you said
what about all those babies who need a
home and can't get a home in the case of
newborn adoption in the united states
that doesn't exist that's completely
made up lump that away with the
boogeyman and bigfoot
in the united states there are an
estimated 36 to 38 couples
who are trying to adopt newborn babies
for every single newborn baby put up for
adoption it is incredibly difficult to
adopt a baby in the united states it's
very expensive people wait years to do
it
friends of mine
family members of mine who have adopted
babies have gone through years and
heartbreak and also because of how
difficult it is because there's a dearth
of babies
in the case of orphanages and the foster
care system that's different
because in that case
you're talking about children who have
been in terrible homes who have very
frequently been abused and neglected
children who are much much older
children who could be even in their
teenage years and so it's wonderful when
people foster those children and take
them into their own homes but that's a
just a totally different sort of
circumstance and so if you're asking me
should homosexuals
homosexual couples or throuples or
single parents be allowed to adopt
single parents of any sort of sexual
persuasion be allowed to adopt newborn
babies i would say of course absolutely
not that's insane you're a child has a
right to his natural mother and father
men and women both have something to
contribute to the rearing of children
marriage actually has a meaning and it's
the same thing that it's meant forever
and not what the libs pretend that it
means today and so no it would be wrong
to deny a child of a
of a real family of a proper marriage
and that context to grow up in just
because of the politically correct
fantasies that we live in today
but if you're asking me
is in in in that case you're saying
should the state
uh give an advantage to the real married
couple that wants to adopt the child or
say no we're agnostic could be a single
mother could be a homosexual
couple or three o could be whatever
in the case of the
foster care
you're saying should homosexuals or
single mothers or whoever be allowed to
take in children
who are not who are languishing in
orphanages
certainly outside the context of a
marriage or outside of a family who are
much older who are not as desired in in
terms of adoption
as the newborns are that's a very
different conversation i would be much
more open to that conversation obviously
because they're just kind of apples and
oranges but the last thing we should do
is to conflate the two
i'm so glad you like that clip now
before you go look we got over a million
subscribers i love that i want a
trillion okay and the first step to a
trillion subscribers is you clicking
that bell so ring it click it ding dong
what a what a bing bong we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you